boys behind you is the military and this
military consists of 100 random players
that if they kill us they win five
thousand dollars and if you die you get
pied in the face okay they're currently
frozen in place to get unfrozen in five
minutes go go go go oh i want the brown
car i want this car they know exactly
what you look like and what you're
wearing i would advise you change
clothes how do i get out of here follow
me i'm headed to changing clothes store
i'm behind you
yeah i can't control this car
really jimmy we've only got two minutes
left
[Music]
excuse me
hey i'm finally to the city i'm at a
close-changing store
i don't know what blends in the best
that basketball court skate park i don't
know if they're gonna check that what
are you doing chris
i'm gonna be a garbage man oh no i'm
gonna die first i'm swimming out into
the middle of the ocean i forgot to make
a strategy so now i'm on top of a
building military the time is up if you
kill me or one of the boys i will give
you five thousand dollars good luck they
have an army of tanks and fighter jets
and all the military equipment you could
ever need oh my god that's a military
jet
yeah oh god
i'm getting beat up by a
civilian oh crap they definitely saw
that just stole a car in front of two
blackhawks
now there's three
jimmy they're shooting at me oh my god i
need to find a new car
all right i'm on a yacht why are you
guys still in the city i'm stuck on a
roof nolan we'll get off of it and run
every five minutes all 100 people in the
military are gonna get a ping on our
location why would you do that just to
make it harder we're gonna get pied i
said in local chat jimmy i'm on my way
to the pier
wait i might appear
oh we just got pinged we just got pinged
you guys you guys you guys i got a ping
got a ping oh they're turning around
there's a helicopter on me boys oh he
shot a missile
oh i just barely missed me this is too
close this is so close
i hit it i hit the helicopter with the
boat i'm just on a nice drive on the
highway right now this is nice there's
something just so peaceful about driving
in gta
never mind there's so many helicopters
dude they are all surrounding me oh
actually i think i'm gonna hide over
here why do they have so many apache
helicopters because they're the military
bro there's a military guy right there
all right i'm driving away let's see if
i can get out of here yo there's so many
people around me there's a tank over
here guys i found the tank i'm fighting
the military with the tank
this guy's bad
i'm blending in with them they think i'm
them so chris you're just sitting in
this tank acting like one of them
i've been blowing them up too oh no
there's a guy in a car now too they're
all chasing me i don't want to get pied
i'm getting out of here there's a tank
oh no it hit me
oh no the boat isn't going anymore oh i
gotta swim
less than one minute until the next
being oh no server pause the hunters i
want to take this time to tell you guys
about display this blade sells high
quality metal art prints that are easy
to install on your wall chris come here
you're a nerd hang this up chris you
like memes here's a dog because you hang
them up with magnets you can easily swap
them out for whatever you want
boom display has millions of designs
ranging from comics movies gaming to
even officially licensed designs from
marvel star wars bethesda and so many
more click the link in the description
to see some of my favorite displays dog
and if you buy one or two of them i'll
automatically give you 34 off three or
four of them 38 percent off and if you
buy over five displays you'll get a 42
discount that is automatically applied
to your card at checkout and on top of
that for every display you purchase they
literally plan to treat click the link
in description before you forget and i'm
gonna unfreeze the hunters there's a
helicopter right on me i'm escaping from
the helicopters with a tractor like the
ball bad really the tractor is slower
than i wanted it to be
oh they popped the tire
they're out to me grass where's my tank
i got to get out of here no no no no no
grass where are you i'm coming
up i'd find a trash can in an alley here
i come
go jimmy run i'm creating a distraction
i'm gonna hide in this random corner
over here
i gotta get out of here this is bad
jimmy i got a whole army on me i'm
taking a lot of damage i don't want to
pie my face oh holy crapstick
oh what do i do i found a river i'm
escaping underwater again i am just
boating through the sewers right now
having a good old time
oh wait there's another ping the ping
again oh no i forgot to keep track
another thing happened i have the entire
military after me right now
how does it feel now there's like 3 000
people around on me i can't believe i'm
hot wiring a taco truck to get away
oh
sorry you're dead no he killed me i'll
take your car and now i can go fast he's
stealing the car
yep the ping just came through and now
they're gonna get on the yacht and then
i'm just gonna take their boat all right
i'm on for y'all i see myself in the in
the highest area where the computers are
he's at the back
seat nerds
i took one of their jet skis military
personnel do you guys know where the
broiler bites billboard is no
that's all i'm gonna say bye
it's at a factory road next to
leicester's factory let's go
i may or may not have literally half the
military chasing me i don't want to go
out like this i don't want to go out
like this guys i need help i need help
i'm down to 10 000 hp
getting chased get out the way i'm down
to 2008 me no i'm gonna die
oh my god i killed jimmy
congratulations molokai winning five
thousand dollars thank you so much
oh i just see cream guys i'm stuck on a
rooftop i need somebody to cover my back
bro
i shot him they're coming up i shot him
again they're off here there's dead guys
everywhere oh they're right next to me
can somebody come help me dude there's
50 red circles around him can't back up
on him
why is this guy not dying
die bro he's so close to dying guys this
is hectic
and he just got pinged talking about
pinged uh we got ping too they're right
on our tail carl keep shooting them keep
shooting them
i killed one come on no one get on go
carl why a motorcycle this is the worst
idea it was the only thing that was
close we needed to get away ready yep ah
i fell
go go go go just go
this car is really slow carl all right
just keep driving forward carl there's a
lot of people in front of us oh there's
a guy right there on us carl
oh no should we get out of the car
carl was killed by nolan nolan i didn't
kill you
oh carl
can somebody please find a towel oh no
they're right on me and i don't have a
car
guys i'm in a big fight right now me too
i've got the whole lobby on me the whole
lobby's on me oh i'm dead i'm gonna die
they're running me over with the car you
animals oh that's all you got nolan is a
tank i got three takes on me jimmy get
away from me i got the pie ready jimmy
let's go nolan died
and he died nolan uh can you look at the
camera
i can't get it oh that's so gross
congratulations on kelly nolan you just
won five thousand dollars
thank you no that's amazing thank you
guys for watching the video hit the
subscribe button if you haven't already
goodbye